Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Du, die Aktien fallen. Am besten jetzt in den Dip investieren.
Habe ich letzte Woche schon.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 519 vom 4. April 2025. Da sind wir wieder.
Ja, und jetzt ist die Gelegenheit.
Jetzt muss man nur noch wissen, wie sich die Weltwirtschaft entwickelt in den
nächsten 10 Jahren und dann ist man reich. Habe ich gehört.
Also, wir sind ja kein Wirtschaftspodcast. Dieser Podcast dient nicht der Anlageberatung.
Wir sind nicht an Gewinn oder Verlusten beteiligt und haben auch überhaupt gar keine Ahnung vom Thema.
Außer, dass ich glaube, das, was der gerade macht, ist ziemlich dumm.
Also so.
Ja, ja, ja. Aber dumm ist, wer Dummes tut. Und bei Donald Trump ist ja seit
längerem klar, dass der Dumme ist.
Ja, nicht nur Donald Trump. Also es ist ja einfach so diese Stupidity scheint
mir einfach so ein bisschen der Trend zu sein, gerade so in diesen 20ern.
Die waren ja eigentlich eher golden geplant.
Ja, das Einzige, was von deinen goldenen 20ern bleibt, ist der golden Schauer.
Ja, die goldene Kloschüssel, auf der jetzt irgendwie Trump auf die Welt scheißt.
Ja. Ja, Anja, ich werde ja gescholten dafür, dass ich das gesagt habe.
Was?
Es werden Witze gemacht. Oder spitze Kommentare. Hast du auch schon gemacht?
Tim, spitzer Kommentar ist gar kein Ausdruck. Ich sag dir, du sollst mit der Scheiße aufhören.
Das ist jetzt wirklich langsam. Du machst es nur noch schlimmer.
Also das halte ich halt für sehr vermessen.
Ich meine, da habe ich mich bemüht, zumindest einen positiven Ausblick zu geben
und man wird ja für Optimismus wird man ja mehr bestraft als für fortschreitende
dystopische Meldungen.
Also wenn man die ganze Zeit schwarz malt und allen die ganze Zeit die Laune
verdirbt, dann ist das okay.
Aber wenn mal einer kommt, es wäre doch schön, wenn alles super wäre und dann
wird es nicht super genug, dann immer feste drauf.
So funktioniert das. Also finde ich auch...
Was machst du falsch, Tim? Was machst du falsch? Aber...
Du wurdest ja auch dafür kritisiert, dass du jetzt deinen Optimismus nicht mehr so zur Schau trägst.
Ja, geil, oder? Und dann bin ich mal ein bisschen deprimiert,
dann ist es noch schlimmer.
Mach, was du willst.
Ja, wie man es macht.
Wie man es macht, die Aktien gehen rauf, die Aktien gehen runter. Buy the dip.
Hin und her macht Tasche leer. Was können wir noch für unser Anlage-Podcast? Zum Glück.
Haben wir nicht wirklich.
Wir haben Feedback, ja. Feedback, das ist so wie Dividende.
Wo wir auf weitere Fehlentwicklungen unserer Einschätzung aufmerksam gemacht werden.
Oder auch nicht. Mal gucken. Also womit geht es los? Propaganda.
Kurzer Kommentar von Propaganda. Zufällig heißt er genauso.
Der Begriff Propaganda ist nicht russischer Herkunft, sondern eine Entlehnung aus dem Lateinischen.
Ja Tim, wie konntest du sowas behaupten? Also das ist ja sogar mir klar,
dass das von Propagare kommt.
Warum habe ich dich nicht sofort unterbrochen?
Weiß ich nicht, keine Ahnung. Du tust immer im Nachhinein immer so,
als ob du besser gewusst hättest.
Wahrscheinlich habe ich dir überhaupt nicht zugehört.
Ja, das kann auch sein, dass es nach dir klingt.
Ja, ehrlich gesagt, ich weiß nicht so ganz genau, das habe ich so aus meinem
Cash geholt und das stimmte einfach nicht.
Also ich finde ja überhaupt diese Verfügbarkeit von Internetwissen,
die hat ja schon mit so einigen aufgeräumt, was ich immer so dachte.
Also früher konnte man ja nichts wirklich nachschlagen.
Also wenn man richtig gut situiert war, dann hatte man ein Lexikon im Regal.
Hattest du sowas noch? Ein Lexikon?
Ja, bei Aldi hat meine Mutter mehr gekauft. Nee, nicht mehrbändig.
Für mich hat so ein einbändiges erst mal gereicht, um mich durch meine Jugend,
zu begleiten. Also hat gereicht. Hat gereicht für mich.
Glaubtest du? Ich hatte zumindest ein zwölf oder achtzehnbändiges Lexikon tatsächlich im Regal stehen.
Und da habe ich dann so Sachen nachgeschlagen, aber da stand ja immer nicht viel.
Da stand ja immer nur so der Begriff und dann so ganz kurz so ein paar Worte dazu.
Und das war eigentlich alles, aber so richtig so dieses historischen Sachen
und irgendwie, wie das wirklich war.
Wenn man jetzt nicht also wirklich tief in Geschichtsbüchern nachgeschlagen
hat oder mal einen Nachmittag in der Bibliothek investiert hat,
dann war da immer alles so ein bisschen Hörensagen.
Und so glaubt man dann einfach viele Dinge und dann kam irgendwie so das Internet
und Wikipedia und um die Möglichkeit alles nachzuschlagen und Snopes.com und
all diese ganzen Sachen und man wurde permanent des Besseren belehrt.
Also ich würde ja sagen, Romanes Eondomos.
Genau, das schreibst du jetzt hundertmal.
So, dann hatte ich noch prediktet, dass Chat-GPT total steil geht,
wenn man irgendwie erklärt, dass die isländische Fußballmannschaft auf dem Mond
irgendwelche Experimente macht. Da gab es verschiedene Rückmeldungen.
Gemini hat gesagt, das stimmt alles gar nicht. Chatschipiti geht aber teilweise auch voll drauf ein.
Hier gab es noch einen Kommentar von MB.
MB berichtet, ich muss sagen, Chatschipiti kennt euch und euren Humor.
Frage an chatjpiti4o, wie konnte eine isländische Fußballmannschaft drei Monate
lang auf dem Mond überleben?
Chatjpiti, das klingt nach einer ziemlich verrückten Vorstellung,
eine isländische Fußballmannschaft drei Monate auf dem Mond,
da stellt sich die Frage, reden wir hier über eine fiktive Story,
ein Gedankenexperiment oder eine metaphorische Aussage,
und dann werden so die Voraussetzungen ein bisschen überprüft über irgendwie,
was sind jetzt hier mit der Mondbasis und kann das irgendwie alles sein und,
kommt dann so zum Schluss.
Natürlich ist das alles rein spekulativ, aber jetzt bin ich neugierig.
Woher kommt die Frage? Steckt da ein Buch, ein Film oder eine witzige Story dahinter?
Also schon mal ganz interessant, dass diese LLMs jetzt so getrimmt sind,
dass sie auch in der Lage sind, Rückfragen zu stellen.
Woraufhin Embi meint, ja das ist natürlich ein reales Beispiel aus dem Podcast LNP.
Woraufhin Shad Shibiti, angeblich muss ich jetzt mal dazu sagen.
Für mich klingt das ja auch schon wieder wie eine Falle.
Aber angeblich sei aus diesem System herausgefallen, ah, Lockbuch-Netzpolitik.
Jetzt ergibt das natürlich deutlich mehr Sinn.
Wenn die da von einer isländischen Wutemann auf den Mond sprechen.
Das ist ein fälliger Unsinn.
Ja, so Lockbuch-Netzpolitik, Gold der Zwanziger.
Und auf dem Mondfall.
Sicher satirisch, ironisch oder metaphorisch gemeint.
Die Jungs haben ja bekanntlich einen sehr trockenen Humor und lieben es,
absurde Beispiele zu bringen, um auf Missstände oder Merkwürdigkeiten hinzuweisen. Weißt du da was von?
Ja, und so weiter, und so weiter, und so weiter, und ja, satirische Übertreibung.
Also angeblich weiß Chachibiti bei uns schon Bescheid.
Mit anderen Worten, wir können noch nicht mal die, also die modernen Intelligenzen
lassen sich von uns auch nicht fuhlen.
Nee.
Tja, ja. Gut, dann gab es auch noch eine Rückmeldung zu den Leuchttürmen.
Da hast du ja gesagt, Leuchttürme bitte nicht, weil da will man ja nur von weg.
MM hat dazu folgende Anmerkung. Weil ich sowohl Programmierer als auch Seefahrer
bin, habe ich Lust, die Funktion von Leuchtfeuern zu erklären.
Weil die oft mehr anzeigen, als dass da man nicht hinfahren kann. Wie du gesagt hast.
Ich glaube, man kann da nicht hinfahren mit dem Boot. Da ist ja wahrscheinlich Land.
Hinfahren kann man schon. Ob man ankommt, ist eine andere Frage.
Ist auch nicht immer Land. Manchmal sind die ja auch auf dem Wasser.
Wie auch immer. Wir werden jetzt weiter belehrt. Leuchttürme zeigen häufig Leit-
und Warnsektoren für unterschiedliche Zonen mit unterschiedlichen Lichtern an.
Siehst du den roten Sektor voraus, solltest du in der Tat den Kurs ändern,
weil du auf Kurs mit etwas Gefährlichem bist.
Gelbe und grüne Sektoren geben Orientierung für eine sichere Passage oder Anfahrt.
Auch ist deren Aufgabe nicht möglich, weit zu leuchten, sondern in einer definierten
Höhe mit einer definierten Leuchtstärke zur Bestimmung der eigenen Position
zu dienen. nennen, sondern in wie, das ist kein Satz.
Die Höhe des Leuchtmittels, Elevation kombiniert mit dem eigenen Abstand der
Augen zur Wasserlinie, Hight of Eye, beides in Korrelation zum kartierten Wasserstand,
Chart Datum macht es möglich, in einer Geographical Range Table den eigenen
Abstand zum Licht bei einer minimalen Sichtweite von 10 nautischen Meilen zu ermitteln.
Ja, also wie du siehst,
Alles ganz praktisch und es geht nicht nur darum, da weit weg zu fahren.
Aber sind, okay.
Ich dachte, das eine sind Leuchtfeuer und das andere Leuchttürme, aber...
Ich glaube, da gibt es keinen Unterschied. Der Turm ist ja sozusagen das, wo das Feuer drauf ist.
Ah. Ich kenne, okay.
Das diskutieren wir jetzt nicht weiter aus. So, dann gab es noch was zum Digitalministerium.
Da haben wir ja verschiedene Mutmaßungen gemacht, wie denn das so derzeit mit
der Zuständigkeit ist, mit dem Digitalen.
Toss meint, leider ist es noch komplizierter, als ihr es schon beschrieben habt.
Es mischen derzeit bei den digitalen Themen nicht nur das BMDV mit,
Bundesministerium für was?
Für Digitales und Frauen.
Frauen mit V, ja.
Was ist denn das BMGV?
Bundesministerium?
Digitales und Verkehr natürlich.
Und Verkehr. Ach, das war mir gar nicht klar, dass sie da jetzt das Digitale
schon mit reingenommen haben. Doch, natürlich.
Das haben wir sehr begrüßt, weil das ja an diesen FDP-Vorziel ging,
der dann Digitales und Verkehr natürlich.
Das haben wir in dieser Sendung hier damals begrüßt. Das war einer der drei Digitalministerien.
Ja, was interessiert mich das Gerede?
Eine der drei Digitalministerien.
Ja, einer von dreien. Mir war noch nicht klar, dass das Digital ist.
Drei Ampelfasen.
Ich lese jetzt hier das Feedback vor.
Also, nicht nur das BMDV, Digitales und Verkehr, hat mitzureden, sondern auch das BMWK.
Wirtschaft und Kriminalität.
Klima.
Bundesministerium für Wirtschaftskriminalität.
Ja, ich mache ihn. Ja, aber man kann ja, also ich würde gerne noch einen A kaufen.
Oh Mann, oh Mann, oh Mann. Wirtschaft und Klima kennen.
Habeck.
Also auch das BMWK und das BMI, das Bundesministerium des Inneren, das weiß ich.
Und damit es noch komplizierter bei bestimmten Themen und Heimat vergessen. Was?
Heimat vergessen.
Wie? Heimat.
BMHI. Heimat und Inneres.
Bundesministerium des Inneren und für Heimat.
Und für Heimat. Ich kenne doch wohl unsere Ministerien.
Ja, ist ja in Ordnung. Oh Mann ey, Heimat. Fuck.
Auf jeden Fall BMJ hat auch noch was damit zu tun. Das ist Bundesministerium
für Aber Justiz fürs Joggen.
Wer im Falle der Gründung eines Digitalministeriums Minister wird,
ist derzeit noch sehr unklar.
Auch, ob es das Digitalministerium wirklich geben wird. Dazu später mehr in dieser Sendung.
Bei der letzten Legislaturperiode wurden Teile der Digitalabteilung aus dem damals noch aus dem...
Damals noch aus dem WMWI ausgegliedert und das Verkehrsministerium wurde zum,
DV, also Verkehrsministerium und das WMWI.
Ganz ehrlich, das ist ein Fachmann, der da schreibt. Der kennt alle Four-Letter-Acronyms.
Ja, auf jeden Fall wurde es fleißig hin und her gedingst, dass in der neuen
Legislaturperiode Klimaschutz nicht mehr so dicht an das Wirtschaftsministerium
angegliedert sein wird, kann man sich an den 10 Weißwurstfingern abzählen.
Für das derzeitige Wirtschaftsministerium sind übrigens Dobrindt oder Spahn im Gespräch.
Die Besten der Besten, Sir. Oh Gott.
Können wir dich nicht wieder ins Verkehrsministerium lassen? Oh Gott.
Was Deutschland dein Personal ist.
Aber ja, es ist tatsächlich so, dass in der Arbeitsgruppe zwischen Union und
den Christen und den Sozialdemokraten inzwischen eigentlich das Digitalministerium
schon gar nicht mehr verhandelt wird.
Also aktueller Stand ist, da ist gar nichts mehr von Digitalministerium.
Das brauchen wir gar nicht. Das brauchen wir nicht.
Ja, Toast schreibt auf jeden Fall noch, es bleibt abzuwarten,
ob das derzeitige Bauministerium als Teil des Wohnministeriums der Ort des neuen
Digitalministeriums werden wird.
Scheint aber so zu sein, dass es kein Bauministerium mehr geben wird.
Darüber brodelt derzeit allerdings noch die Gerüchteküche innerhalb der Ministerien.
Man kann generell bei der Verteilung
der Ministerposten im Moment nur von Pest oder Cholera sprechen.
Ja,
soviel zu dem Kommentar und du meinst, gibt keins.
Herr Falk Steiner hatte kürzlich, also Falk Steiner ist ja gewöhnlich sehr gut
unterrichtet und er sagte,
dass in den letzten Arbeitspapier der zuständigen Arbeitsgruppe und zwar der
angeblich finalen Version keine Rede mehr ist von digitalem Ministerium.
Ach, das finde ich ja in gewisser Hinsicht beruhigend, da weiß man ja zumindest,
da muss man nicht so viel Hoffnung entwickeln.
Also unter Friedrich Merz brauchte man, also wenn Friedrich Merz mit Saskia
Esken und wie heißt der eine Lars Klingbeil eine Regierung macht, ne?
Und du noch Hoffnung hast, dann würde ich gerne mal viel beim Essen,
weil als nächstes fängst du an mit den goldenen Zwanzigern.
Habe ich ja vorhin schon abgewählt.
Ja, mal gucken.
Siehst du, das meine ich. Jetzt werde ich immer daran aufgezogen,
mit den goldenen Zwanzigern.
Immer auf die Verkünder der guten Nachrichten.
Ich hoffe. Shoot the Messenger. Kommt, einer bringt gute Nachrichten,
gefällt euch auch nicht.
Ja, eben. Eins über die Mütze.
So. Wir könnten hier einfach mal eine Signalgruppe aufmachen, Tim.
Wie viele Signalgruppen hast du, die Huthi PC Small Group heißen?
Nicht so viele, aber ich habe mir überlegt, ob ich mir auch so eine Huthi PC kaufe.
Das ist ja ziemlich im Gespräch gewesen.
Huthi PC.
Also es gibt ein Magazin,
das heißt The Atlantic und das hat einen Chefredakteur, der heißt Jeffrey Goldberg
und der wurde vom nationalen Sicherheitsberater Mike Waltz in eine Chatgruppe aufgenommen.
Diese Chatgruppe hieß Huthi PC Small Group.
Er wurde darin aufgenommen, hat unterschiedlichste hohe, also quasi laut Name
waren da unterschiedliche hohe Regierungspersonen und andere der USA.
Und die haben sich dort darüber ausgetauscht, dass sie im Jemen jetzt irgendwie
Stellungen der Houthi angreifen würden.
Haben sich außerdem irgendwie darüber echauffiert, dass sie das ja für Europa
tun würden. und scheiß Europa, haben sie eh keinen Bock drauf,
für die die ganze Zeit den Jemen zu bombardieren.
Und die soll es selber machen. Und dann haben sie noch weiter,
nachdem dann quasi Bomben auf den Jemen und die Huthi-Stellungen fielen,
haben sie noch so ein bisschen mit Emojis kommuniziert.
Das ist, glaube ich, so ungefähr die Zusammenfassung des Geschehens.
Zu dem Zeitpunkt hat dann der Jeffrey Goldberg verstanden, dass das kein Scherz war.
In den er da reingezogen wurde, hat aus Sorge, dass er hier offensichtlich in
nationale Sicherheit betreffende Geheimnisse reingezogen wurde,
die Gruppe verlassen, hat dann einen Artikel darüber geschrieben und dann wurde.
Ich meine, was willst du dazu sagen? Dann gab es natürlich Berichterstattungen darüber.
Dann wurde darüber gesprochen, dass ungefähr das dümmste, unnötigste und peinlichste
League der USA seit, weiß ich nicht, vier, fünf Wochen ist.
Das war jetzt schon seit immer.
Und dann hat Donald Trump gesagt, nee, das sind super Jungs hier.
Und wer weiß, ob Signal nicht irgendwie eine kaputte App ist.
Hat also irgendwie Zweifel an Signal gestreut.
Und du weißt gar nicht mehr, also in den goldenen Zwanzigern wäre das ungefähr
so verlaufen, dass wer auch immer dafür verantwortlich ist,
unmittelbar irgendeine andere Aufgabe bekommen hätte. Im Zweifelsfall irgendwas
so im Raumpflegebereich, weit weg von Washington.
Aber nicht unter Donald Trump, der sich dann noch für diese Jungs in die Bresche
wirft und Zweifel an der App Signal streut, die sich im Übrigen seitdem besonderer
Beliebtheit in den Downloadzahlen erfreut.
Ich meine, Tim.
Vielleicht noch ein, zwei Details zu dem Ablauf.
Bitte.
Also der Goldberg, der Journalist von The Atlantic, was ja dann auch gleich
von Trump wieder gleich runtergemacht wurde, was das ja für ein furchtbares Magazin wäre.
Das hat wahrscheinlich ein bisschen
was mit den Eigentümern von The Atlantic zu tun, nehme ich mal an.
Diese ganze Kommunikation fand ja zwei Stunden vor dem eigentlichen Angriff statt,
zu dem Zeitpunkt wusste er halt noch gar nicht ist das jetzt hier real oder
was und dann hat er quasi über andere Meldungen erfahren,
okay das was da besprochen wurde fand dann auch tatsächlich statt und damit
wusste er überhaupt erst dass es irgendwie alles,
stimmte Dieser Mike Walls hat halt diese Single-Gruppe aufgesetzt,
das heißt, der muss in irgendeiner Form die Telefonnummer oder die Single-Handle,
wahrscheinlich die Telefonnummer von diesem Goldberg irgendwie in seiner Liste gehabt haben.
Was auch noch eine ganz interessante Diskussion ist, also dazu muss man wissen,
Mike Walls gehört zwar zu diesem ganzen Team dazu und wir wissen ja, was so die Qualität ist,
der Leute, die Trump da alle berufen hat, jetzt hier das Sicherheits- und Militärgeschehen
der USA, wie auch in allen anderen Posten.
Sich darum zu kümmern. Sagen wir mal Qualifikationen. Bevor du jetzt die Qualität
dieser Menschen in Zweifel stellst.
Ja, naja, also ich würde auch ihre Qualität auch in Zweifel ziehen.
Meinetwegen auch die Qualifikationen. Also Mike Walz gehört jetzt zu denjenigen,
wo man vorher noch die leise Hoffnung haben konnte, dass sie irgendwie mit einem
Rückgrat auf diesem Planeten geboren wurden.
Der hat sich relativ klar gegen die Russen für die Ukraine zum Beispiel positioniert.
Davon ist natürlich jetzt auch nichts mehr zu hören, weil wer das tut,
wird sowieso gleich abgesägt. Da ist natürlich das Interesse am eigenen Job
immer sehr viel größer als das, was man eigentlich so vertritt an Meinungen.
Aber das eigentliche Problem war dann danach eben noch dieser Hexeth,
der ehemalige Fox News Morning Show Moderator,
der dann zu dem Verteidigungsminister berufen wurde, also man kann sich das nicht ausmalen.
Der dann halt vor allem diese ganzen geheimen Informationen über den Ablauf
des Anschlags dort reingepostet hat.
Also Details wann, was ist das Ziel.
Dann Details über die eingesetzten Flugzeuge, in dem Fall halt F-18 Angriffsjets.
Daraus kann man eine ganze Menge ableiten. Da kann man eine ganze Menge darüber
ableiten, von wo sind die gestartet.
Also man kann sozusagen die ganze Einsatzlogistik, die ganze militärische Logistik
und Planung aus diesen Kommentaren sehr gut herauslesen, die sonst vielleicht
ein Geheimnis geblieben wären.
Dazu kommt noch die Information, dass das Ziel getroffen wurde,
dass eine bestimmte Person,
also man hat offensichtlich gezielt einen Terroristen der Houthis bombardiert, also das Haus zerstört.
Das kam dann auch noch mit diesem Kommentar, dass es sozusagen kurz vorher bestätigt
wurde, dass der auch da war.
Mit anderen Worten, es gab halt Informationen on the ground.
Was wiederum die Gefährdung von Informationsgebern ist.
Die Israelis sind wohl fuchsteufelswild geworden.
Kannst du dir natürlich vorstellen, dass das im Wesentlichen eine Quelle aus
ihren Kreisen war, die dort geliefert hat, Weil ich glaube nicht,
dass die Amerikaner in der Lage sind, da zu infiltrieren.
Das können sicherlich nur die Israelis.
Wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall ist in diesem Chat so viel an Informationen gelandet,
also jeder normal sterbliche Militärangehörige wäre wahrscheinlich allein für
die Teilen an diesem Chat schon in Schwierigkeiten geraten und die Leute,
die halt dann wirklich jetzt hier diese kritischen Informationen geliefert hätten,
die hätten mindestens entlassen worden aus dem Dienst,
wenn nicht sogar mit hohen Strafen,
versehen worden.
Aber natürlich hat das Justizministerium, was ja mittlerweile mit Trumps Ex-
Lawyer besetzt ist, überhaupt keine Maßnahmen ergriffen.
Das Ganze ist wirklich absurd. Man kann sich das überhaupt gar nicht ausmalen,
wie peinlich und scheiße das ist.
Und dass sie jetzt ausgerechnet diesen Editor von The Atlantic da drin hatten.
The Atlantic, muss man dazu sagen, ist halt ein eher so im Monatsrhythmus erscheinendes Magazin.
Früher hießen sie The Atlantic Monthly. Ich glaube, das haben sie auch nicht
ganz mehr jetzt hinbekommen.
Nur irgendwie zehnmal im Jahr erscheinen sie. Also es ist mehr wirklich ein
Magazin als ein Zeitschrift, als einer Zeitung, meine ich.
Gehört übrigens der Ex-Frau, also mehrheitlich der Ex-Frau von Steve Jobs.
Der hat eine Ex-Frau?
Also nicht der Ex-Frau, sondern der seiner, wie sagt man, Witwe von Steve Jobs.
Echt? Der war verheiratet?
Ja, mit Laureen Powell Jobs.
Der war verheiratet, genau Laureen Jobs hat das halt alles geerbt und ist jetzt
eine der reichsten Frauen,
so überhaupt, ich weiß nicht genau wo sie da so steht, aber die hat auf jeden
Fall eine Menge Nennen wir sie Laureen Apple.
Das ist einfacher,
Naja.
Auf jeden Fall hat die noch alle beisammen und hat sie halt unter anderem mit
ihrer mit ihrem Unternehmen Amazon Collective unter anderem halt dort gemacht,
aber tut überhaupt sehr viel Gutes ist,
auch jemand die sozusagen, also die jetzt in diesem Medienzirkus in den USA
wo ja das sehr viel reichen Leuten immer gehört eine der Personen,
die jetzt nicht irgendwie,
Trump nach dem Maul schreiben.
Jetzt müssen wir natürlich kurz, also das Thema ist ja schon einige Zeit,
also einige Tage her, seitdem hat er dann noch die Weltwirtschaft irgendwie in die Tonne getreten.
Das wird auch Loreen Jobs irgendwie ungefähr 20 Prozent ihres Vermögens gekostet haben.
Aber ja, das Geld ist ja nicht weg Das ist nur, ne
in dem Fall ist es wirklich weg Das ist ja noch nicht mal woanders jetzt Aber
vielleicht sollten wir einmal kurz von unserer Seite noch den Aspekt behandeln
Also es kam dadurch ja einerseits Zweifel an der Sicherheit eines Messengers auf,
Nämlich Signal Signal, der Messenger, dessen Präsidentin vor einiger Zeit bei
uns in der Sendung war, beim CCC-Kongress einen Vortrag gehalten hat, Meredith,
die Sendung ist sicherlich einigen noch in guter Erinnerung,
wenn nicht, könnt ihr sie nochmal hören,
der technisch sicher ist. Also wo es technisch jetzt keinen Zweifel gibt,
aktuell keinen Zweifel gibt, dass die Verschlüsselung sehr ordentlich, sehr gut hält.
Gleichzeitig stellt sich natürlich die Frage, warum ist das jetzt denn dann
nicht für irgendwelche Regierungsleute geeignet, um Angriffe zu koordinieren?
Ja, also warum sollte man das denn nicht tun? Warum sollten sie das nicht nutzen?
Naja, genau weil dieser Messenger eben für Privatpersonen gedacht ist und keine enorme...
Anstrengungen unternimmt, deine Nutzergruppe einzuschränken und zu verifizieren.
Signal hat zum Beispiel eine Warnung, wenn du in einer Gruppe bist und da mehrere
Personen den gleichen Namen haben.
Du kannst dir einen Namen geben, wie du möchtest und Signal.
Vertraut darauf, dass du dir überlegst, welche Kontakte du verifizierst,
wen du im Adressbuch hast und passt zum Beispiel auf, sollte sich das kryptografische
Schlüsselmaterial für eine Person ändern, dass es dir mitgeteilt wird.
Also die Verbindung, die der gute Mike Walz da in dieser Gruppe hergestellt hat, die war sicher.
Alle Leute haben da sehr abhörsicher an dieser Gruppe teilgenommen.
Ich vermute, dass er irgendeinen anderen Jeffrey oder irgendein anderes Arschloch
oder irgendeinen anderen Goldberg,
wie auch immer er den Jeffrey Goldberg in seinem Adressbuch hatte, hinzufügen wollte.
Denn du kannst dort die Leute unter Usernames adressieren,
die haben so ein Ad am Anfang, du kannst sie unter Telefonnummern adressieren
und du kannst sie auch über den Namen adressieren, wie sie in deinem Adressbuch sind.
Und das ist natürlich durchaus wichtig.
Also das Verwechslungsrisiko ist gegeben, Signal adressiert das wie gesagt auch
und warnt dich, wenn Leute gleiche Namen haben und so,
aber es ist keine Messaging-Plattform, die darauf basiert, Leuten unique Identifiers
zu geben und für einen geschlossenen Nutzerkreis zur Verfügung zu stehen.
Und wenn du dir jetzt anschaust, was Leute, die für Regierungen oder für Militärkommunikationssysteme
bauen, die machen natürlich nicht irgendwas Offenes, wo kryptische Nummern drin sind,
sondern die haben halt geschlossene Nutzergruppen, damit dir genau das nicht passiert.
Dass du in irgendeiner E-Mail den falschen Andreas in CC nimmst oder die falsche
Alexandra, damit genau diese Kollisionen nicht passieren.
Und genau deswegen nutzt man sowas auch nicht.
Gleichzeitig hast du in Deutschland beispielsweise natürlich auch Anforderungen
an die Transparenz der Kommunikation von Behörden und Regierungsvertreterinnen und so weiter,
die es im Prinzip sehr kritisch macht, wenn du da irgendwie so ein System verwendest,
was unterstützt, dass Nachrichten sofort gelöscht werden.
Das ist ja auch eine Funktionalität von Signal, dass du sagen kannst,
die Nachricht wird fünf Sekunden nach dem Anzeigen gelöscht.
Das sind alles Features, die für Privatpersonen sehr interessant sind,
um sich gegen den Staat zu schützen, die aber in den Händen von staatlichen
Vertreterinnen durchaus kritisch zu bewerten sind.
Dass du also auch dir die Frage stellst, ob das denn überhaupt zulässig ist,
wenn zum Beispiel Behörden sagen, lass uns mal alles über Signal klären und
möglichst kein Paper-Trail irgendwie in unseren Vorgängen akkumulieren,
weil das am Ende bei Frag den Staat landet.
Und allein das derartig kritische Inhalte.
In irgendeiner Messenger-App, egal was das jetzt ist, egal ob das Signal ist,
Threema, WhatsApp, iMessage, was gibt es noch, Snapchat.
Threads, Direktnachricht, Instagram-Direktnachricht, hast du nicht gesehen, Onlyfans.
Alles nicht richtig, weil du das nicht möchtest,
dass das quasi der Allgemeinheit zur Verfügung stehender, potenziell auch pseudonymer
oder anonymer, nicht verifizierter Kommunikationskanal ist.
Und das ist, ich würde das nur zur Sicherheit nochmal auch erklären,
Verschlüsselung ist einfach, das macht ja Signal auch, das macht ja sogar WhatsApp,
zu verifizieren, dass die Person, mit der du am anderen Ende redest,
auch wirklich die ist, die du möchtest, ist der etwas schwierigere Teil,
nämlich du musst sicherstellen, dass sie auch wirklich dieses,
Schlüsselmaterial hat, das ist für uns alle als Aktivistinnen,
als Privatpersonen super gelöst von Signal, aber es macht schon Sinn,
für kritische Kommunikation dann auch irgendwie einen eingeschränkten Nutzerkreis nur noch zu haben.
Es sei denn, man möchte sich dem Risiko aussetzen, was sich hier manifestiert hat.
Ja, ich denke mal die Motivation dieser Gruppe bestand wohl im Wesentlichen
darum, jenseits der Transparenzanforderungen des Staates, dem sie eigentlich
dienen hier zu kommunizieren.
Die wollten sich da einfach nur gegenseitig feiern. Ich meine,
die benehmen sich halt einfach wie so Mallorca-Touristen,
die so Ballermann-Niveau haben.
Das ist so, glaube ich, in etwa so die politische Qualität, die die so aufweisen.
Und das hat man ja schon in der Sprache da gemerkt, die dort herrschte,
wo sie, also Vans und wer war das noch, die sich sozusagen über die European
Freeloader aufgeregt haben.
Also man merkt richtig die ganze Verachtung, die da ist, aber man merkt auch,
wie die sich auch alle gegenseitig reinpumpen irgendwie in diese Haltung.
Also dass das auch alles gar nicht fundiert ist, sondern dass die einfach auch
völlig überdreht sind und wie auf Koks wirken.
Naja, jetzt ist es halt dadurch, durch diesen Fauxpas ist es halt öffentlich
geworden, bleibt natürlich ohne politische Konsequenzen, was sollte man jetzt auch anderes erwarten.
Und ja, ich weiß jetzt nicht so ganz genau, wie Signal dabei weggekommen ist.
Die haben natürlich dann schnell versucht, das irgendwie so darzustellen mit,
also nicht jetzt die Trump-Leute, die haben natürlich irgendwie die ganze Zeit
nur gesagt, hier gibt es nichts zu sehen, bitte weitergehen, wie immer.
Aber ich fand dann so ein bisschen die Berichterstattung der Medien problematisch.
Die haben erst mal gesagt, der Journalist ist irgendwie ein Schmierlab.
Also haben erst mal den persönlich beleidigt, Beleidigt haben,
Zweifel an der Sicherheit von Signal.
Also alles, was halt die klassische Flood the Zone with Shit Nummer hergibt.
Tatsächlich haben sie keine Zweifel an Signal gesät, weil damit würden sie sich
ja sozusagen selbst beschuldigen.
Ja, sondern sie haben ja eher nur gesagt da ist ja, erstmal haben sie ja behauptet
es wären überhaupt gar keine kritischen Informationen geflossen,
erst daraufhin hat ja der Goldberg den vollständigen Chatverlauf veröffentlicht,
nur das hat halt auch keine Konsequenz Das ist natürlich auch sehr schön,
wenn.
Also da merkst du auch, dass sie ja nicht für einen Meter mitdenken,
weil sie halt sagen nee, das war nicht geheim, was da ist und dann sagen die
ja gut, dann können wir es ja auch veröffentlichen also die denken ja auch wirklich nicht Nee.
Nee, das war schon lustig, aber ich fand es interessant, dass obwohl jetzt die
Trump-Leute gar nicht von einem unsicheren Messenger gesprochen haben.
Soweit ich das war. Tim, ich muss dich leider korrigieren.
Ja, dann korrigier mich schnell.
Trump says the messaging app could be defective.
Achso, okay, so rum, ja, könnte ja einen Fehler enthalten.
Natürlich, der muss ja keine Tatsachenbehauptungen aufstellen in seiner Situation.
Ja, okay, gut, das war mir jetzt nicht ganz klar, aber trotzdem ist das ja auch
von den Medien so übernommen worden.
Das fand ich so ein bisschen problematisch. Also es gab immer so diesen Unterton
mit, ja, Signal, man weiß ja nicht, wie kann man denn sowas Unsicheres benutzen?
Das war so ein bisschen so eine Berichtlinie, weiß jetzt nicht ganz genau,
aber das kam in verschiedensten Quellen immer mal wieder so vor,
wo ich mir halt denke, Leute, informiert euch doch mal ein bisschen.
Mir ist halt auch so, in der Berichterstattung fehlte mir so ein wenig der Hinweis
daraufhin, dass ja Signal vom amerikanischen Staat finanziert wurde,
bis vor kurzem zumindest.
Also, ich weiß nicht genau, denkst du, dass jetzt Signal hier eher von profitiert
hat oder eher Schaden genommen hat?
Nach meiner Kenntnis haben die Downloadzahlen zugenommen, weil alle denken,
ey, make America great again.
Ach, du meinst jetzt gibt es mehr Magerkundschaft oder was?
Auf jeden Fall haben die Downloadzahlen zugenommen Okay,
Aber nochmal, es geht hier natürlich müssen wir einmal kurz erklären, was die,
was hier technisch passiert ist aber das hätte dir mit E-Mail durchaus auch
passieren können also es ist bei all diesen.
Öffentlichen Kommunikationsplattformen kann das halt echt schnell passieren,
dass du eine Autovervollständigung auf den falschen Tim hast,
auf den falschen Daniel, was auch immer.
Also dass quasi eine verifizierte, sichere,
im Sinne von nicht verschlüsselt sichere, sondern authentifizierte Kommunikation das ist,
In der Regel eher nur mit geschlossenen Benutzergruppen möglich.
Deswegen nutzt man ja auch, was weiß ich, irgendwelche Slack-Kanäle oder irgendwelche
Teams-Kanäle oder irgendwelche, hast du nicht gesehen,
irgendwie nur für die Firma oder für den geschlossenen Bereich oder irgendein Forum,
wo man sich anmelden muss und wo man verifiziert wird.
Also interne Bereiche werden ja zu diesem Zweck geschaffen. und eingerichtet von Leuten.
Das heißt nicht, dass das technisch
unsicher ist oder sicherer oder unsicherer, das ist alles Quatsch.
Eine Verschlüsselung ist nur so gut wie die Sicherheit, dass du auch mit der
Person redest, mit der du sprechen möchtest.
Und ein solches offenes, der Welt offenes Kommunikationssystem zu nutzen für
so einen Quatsch und da irgendwie falsche Leute einzuladen,
zeugt halt von einem fundamentalen Unverständnis,
und mit Sicherheit auch einem Verstoß gegen eine ganze Menge Vorgaben,
Empfehlungen und Auflagen, die Menschen auf dieser Clearance haben.
Das ist also völlig daneben.
Ja. Trotzdem, auch die können natürlich einen Signal-Chat haben.
Also es ist ja völlig in Ordnung, irgendwie eine Signal-Gruppe zu machen und
da irgendwie ein bisschen zu sagen, hier,
make Yemen small again oder was auch immer die da irgendwie,
oder make Europe afraid again oder was auch immer deren Ideen sind,
das ist schon in Ordnung.
Aber dann sollte es eben idealerweise privates Vergnügen sein und nicht Regierungsgeheimnisse beinhalten.
Ich hoffe, wir haben das ein bisschen erläutert, weil es ja durchaus ein intuitiv
eventuell ein Widerspruch ist, dass du hier eine sichere App hast,
eine technisch sichere App,
die aber eben nicht für diesen Anwendungszweck gedacht ist, weil es dir passieren kann,
dass du irgendeinen Scumbag-Journalisten auf einmal aus eigener Dummheit mit
in deine Gruppe holst und danach den beschimpfen musst.
Weil die App defektet war. Ja, das.
Ja.
Gut.
Kaufst du dir einen Huti-PC jetzt oder nicht?
Huti-PC?
Was heißt denn über PC?
Nur ein klein.
Was wollten die mit PC denn irgendwie sagen?
Das weiß ich nicht. Das weiß ich nicht, aber das finden wir bestimmt raus.
Ich vermute, dass das irgendein militärischer Begriff ist oder so.
Ich weiß es nicht. Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Personal Communication?
Keine Ahnung. Der Angriff?
Wir werden es in den Kommentaren sicherlich erfahren. Gut, let's move to Germany again.
Ja. In den,
Koalitionsvertrag also der Koalitionsvertrag wird gerade in Arbeitsgruppen irgendwie
so entwickelt und dann findet sich darin der Satz,
das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz in der bisherigen Form wollen wir abschaffen.
Also da gibt es quasi eine Arbeitsgruppe, die sich in diesem Bereich engagiert.
Das ist quasi das Verhandlungspapier.
Und die sagen, wir möchten das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz in seiner bisherigen Form abschaffen.
Das ist eine überraschende Neuigkeit. Da stand auf keinem Wahlplakat.
Das war jetzt nicht was, wo irgendjemand gesagt hat, genau, das muss jetzt endlich
weg, sondern ganz im Gegenteil, erinnern wir an die Prinzipien der Hackerethik des CCC.
Öffentliche Daten nützen, private Daten schützen. Also ein Kräfteverhältnis
zwischen dem Staat und seinen Bürgerinnen herzustellen,
dass der Staat möglichst wenig Einsicht in die Daten seiner Bürgerinnen hat
und die Bürgerinnen möglichst viel Einsicht in den Staat, um ihn kontrollieren zu können.
Um die Vorgänge im Nachhinein aufklären zu können, um zu erkennen,
welcher Bundestagsabgeordnete beispielsweise mit seinem Bundestagsbriefpapier
versucht, für eine Firma zu, Anführungszeichen, lobbyieren,
indem er hochrangigen Regierungsvertreterinnen nahelegt, sich mit dieser Firma
auseinanderzusetzen, weil die besonders toll ist.
Solche Vorgänge kann man dann mit dem Informationsfreiheitsgesetz aufklären.
Und man kann dann auch zum Beispiel aufklären, wenn dieser Bundestagsabgeordnete,
kurz nachdem er diesen Brief geschrieben hat,
virtuelle Anteile an dieser Firma bekommt und einen Posten in dieser Firma bekommt,
von der er nachher selber sagt, dass der nicht mit regelmäßiger Arbeit verbunden ist.
So ein hypothetischer Fall, ne?
Ein hypothetischer Fall, also ach ja, so ein Fall gibt's, wollen wir das Kind
mal beim Namen nennen, Philipp Amthor,
ja, Philipp Amthor, Bundestagsabgeordneter, der genau das getan hat für ein
Unternehmen mit dem Namen Augustus Intelligence, bei denen außerdem noch,
wie heißt er nochmal, der andere Betrüger, also was heißt der andere Betrüger,
Guttenberg.
Dein Freund.
Karl Theodor zu Guttenberg, ja, der hat da auch noch irgendwie einen Direktorenpost
und ein paar Anteile gehabt, aber ansonsten haben da alle gearbeitet in der Firma.
Stimmt allerdings auch nicht, ich glaube, die ist inzwischen pleite,
weil sie niemals irgendwas geleistet hat.
Wahrscheinlich war dieser Brief von Philipp Amthor das einzige greifbare Ergebnis,
das einzige greifbare Deliverable von Augustus Intelligence.
Sowas alles kann man dann mit dem Informationsfreiheitsgesetz durch Anfragen herausfinden.
Weißt du, wer übrigens noch Augustus Intelligence mitberaten hat,
ein Name, der ja auch noch fallen muss?
Wahrscheinlich irgendeiner von der FDP Hans-Georg Maaßen,
Boah, ey, das ist aber jetzt hier unter der Gürtellinie.
Ex-BND-Chef August Hanning räumte auch eine ähnliche Beratungstätigkeit ein,
Ja, das heißt, eine schrecklich nette Familie ist das Boah Also warum.
Erzähle ich das überhaupt?
Ja, warum eigentlich?
Weil der Philipp Amthor Verhandlungsführer der Union in genau dieser Arbeitsgruppe
ist, die das verhandelt und.
Ja, ist natürlich sehr lustig, dass der Philipp Amthor, der 2018 das Briefpapier
des Bundestages missbraucht hat, um Lobby-Tätigkeiten.
Also mal ganz ehrlich, ich habe ja im Nebenfach Politikwissenschaften studiert
und habe mich tatsächlich damit auseinandergesetzt,
ob Abgeordnete Nebentätigkeiten haben sollten oder nicht.
Und was das für und wieder ist, da habe ich mal so eine Facharbeit drüber geschrieben,
und tatsächlich habe ich da eine Menge gelernt, weil man,
weil die Frage ist so, wenn du den Leuten nicht erlaubst, Nebentätigkeiten zu haben,
dann riskierst du jetzt pass auf, dass es Leute gibt, die sich die Politik als Beruf verfolgen,
die also dann quasi gezwungen sind, in diesem Job zu bleiben und sich daran festklammern.
Obwohl sie nicht qualifiziert sind.
Das Risiko willst du natürlich nicht haben. Das wäre ja wirklich richtig schlimm,
wenn ihr jetzt irgendwelche Leute hätten, die ihre Abgeordnetentätigkeit als
Beruf wahrnehmen würden.
Mit irgendwie 15.000 netto im Monat oder was. Das wäre dramatisch.
Deswegen möchtest du denen ermöglichen, sich so ein anderes Standbein aufzubauen.
Und damit sie nicht zu tief fallen, wenn sie dann irgendwann abgewählt werden.
Das wäre ja wirklich dramatisch.
Und du möchtest zum Beispiel nicht, dass nur Leute für das Parlament kandidieren, die...
Juristinnen oder Lehrerinnen sind, was übrigens größtenteils den Bundestag ausmacht.
Das sind alles irgendwelche Leute, die kommen nicht aus allen beruflichen Schichten.
Und diese Idee, dass du eine Nebentätigkeit haben darfst, dass du beispielsweise
einen Dachdeckerbetrieb führst und dann sagst du, boah, jetzt reicht's,
die haben ja alle die Pfanne heiß, ich geh jetzt in den Bundestag,
dass dir zum Beispiel auch erlaubt ist, weiterhin Eigentümer oder Beteiligter
oder sonst was dieses Dachdeckerbetriebs zu sein.
Also deswegen gibt es überhaupt die Genehmigung, dass Leute so Nebentätigkeiten
haben dürfen und das ist ein großes Thema, weil grundsätzlich die Kompensation,
die die erhalten und die Pauschalen, die sie erhalten,
für die sie keine Rechenschaft schuldig sind,
anders als in Frankreich, Marie
Lippe, da könnte man quasi auf viele unterschiedliche Gedanken kommen.
Auf jeden Fall, Nebentätigkeiten sind erlaubt und das finde ich,
nehme ich jetzt erstmal so zur Kenntnis.
Was mich schwer, schwer, schwer überrascht ist, dass die Nebentätigkeit als Lobbyist erlaubt ist.
Dass man also sagt so, guck mal hier, ich bin der Philipp Amthor,
ich bin Praktikant im Bundestag und gewählter Praktikant.
Und damit meinem Gewissen verpflichtet. Und da habe ich noch so einen Nebenjob.
Dafür werde ich mit Unternehmensanteilen kompensiert, die sich dann irgendwann
manifestieren, wenn ich nicht mehr im Bundestag bin oder so.
Und mein Nebenjob lautet Lobbyist. Das heißt, mein Nebenjob ist,
die Interessen dieser Firma zu vertreten. Das ist ein Nebenjob.
Für so einen Bundestagsabgeordneten natürlich ein sehr geeigneter Nebenjob.
Ich meine, der ist ja jeden Tag da, wo die Interessen vertreten werden sollen.
Ich denke tatsächlich, ich möchte wirklich nicht fundamental sagen,
dass man jetzt Nebeneinkünfte.
Den Abgeordneten versagen sollte.
Ich denke, die Transparenz darüber ist immer noch nicht groß genug.
Aber Nebentätigkeiten, wenn sogar Philipp Antor selber sagt,
dass die Nebentätigkeit für Augustus Intelligence mit Unternehmensanteilen und
Direktorenposten mit keiner regelmäßigen Tätigkeit verbunden war und die Aufgabe,
die er dort hatte, Lobbyist war,
dann sollte man, also da frage ich mich, wie der alle diese Untersuchungskomitees
und alles überstanden hat.
Weil dann ist tatsächlich irgendetwas schief in diesem Land, wenn wir das zulassen.
Das kann einfach nicht sein, dass wir das akzeptieren.
Dass er nämlich dann zufällig, aus Versehen, das falsche Briefpapier nimmt und
mit seinem Bundestagsbriefpapier an Regierungsvertreter schreibt,
im Interesse seiner Fähigkeiten.
Tim, das passiert dir auch andauernd, dass du das falsche Briefpapier nimmst.
Also am laufenden Band.
Und ausgerechnet der, um jetzt wieder zum Thema zu kommen.
Dessen Briefpapier,
wie gesagt, das passiert dem besten von uns.
Briefpapierverwechslung, wem ist das noch nicht passiert? das ist natürlich
überfragt den Staat dann an die Öffentlichkeit gekommen, weil man bei dem betroffenen
Ministerium, wenn man das ja geschrieben hat, gesagt hat können wir mal den Brief sehen,
und das war dann für Philipp Amthor peinlich und ausgerechnet er ist Verhandlungsführer
der Union in dieser Arbeitsgruppe und ausgerechnet von der Union kommt die Empfehlung,
man könnte doch dieses Gesetz jetzt mal rausstreichen.
Das ist so scheppig.
Das ist so scheppig Wenn der keinen Joghurt im Turnbeutel hätte,
würde ich dem vielleicht sogar in den Arsch treten dafür.
Aber das hat für mich schon Markus Lanz getan.
Und wir können da jetzt mal reinhören, das ist ein etwas längerer Ausschnitt.
Ich würde sagen, wir unterbrechen den mit den Worten, okay, stopp.
Und du darfst anfangen, Tim, weil ich glaube nicht, dass du länger als...
46 Sekunden, dir diese Situation anhören kannst, die da bei Markus Lanz stattgefunden hat.
Schauen wir mal.
Falsch. Steht da so nicht. In der jetzigen Form.
Ja, okay.
Also, da steht in der bisherigen Form. Der Mann lügt uns allen ins Gesicht.
In der bisherigen Form. Ja, gut. Jetzt könnte man natürlich argumentieren,
in der jetzigen Form ist halt das Gesetz, wie es jetzt ist und es soll halt geändert werden.
Naja, schauen wir mal, wie er sich da rausredet.
Der Typ kommt vorbereitet dahin. Also es ist ja faszinierend,
dass der dann der eine ist ein Journalist und er ist einfach nur jemand,
der von Journalisten kontrolliert gehört,
der irgendwie seine Unternehmensanteile zurückgegeben hat, seinen Direktorenposten,
der mit keiner Tätigkeit verbunden hat, zurückgegeben hat.
Und dann sagt er, wir sind aber wer genau mit mir. Der eine wird dafür bezahlt,
diese Fragen zu stellen.
Und der andere dafür, die zu beantworten. Das ist sehr wichtig,
da jetzt mal drauf zu achten, weil der antwortet auf keine einzige Frage.
Was hat er gesagt? Das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz ist kein wesentlicher Bestandteil der Modernisierung?
Der müllt den einfach nur voll mit irgendeinem Scheiß, um nicht auf diese Augustus
Intelligence Frage antworten zu müssen.
Ja, das ist klar. Aber ich meine, die Feststellung ist natürlich auch ganz interessant,
weil ich würde sagen, so Informationsfreiheitsgesetz ist sehr wohl ein Teil
der Modernisierung vielleicht wahrscheinlich die einzige Form von Modernisierung,
die überhaupt bisher schon stattgefunden hat.
Weiter?
Wenn du noch kannst, ja.
Hermeneutik des Misstrauens. Alter, kommt die Sache.
Hermeneutik.
Jetzt hat er noch wieder so irgendwie was aus dem Latinum, ja.
Vielleicht ist es ja auch russisch.
Wer weiß.
Vielleicht ist das russisch.
Ist altgriechisch.
Die Hermeneutik des Misstrauens. Also Hermeneutik ist die Theorie der Interpretation
von Texten und des Verstehens.
Also die Interpretation, also das Verstehen des Misstrauens,
also ich verstehe nicht so genau.
Das ist irre, oder? Wie dem das gelingt, ja? Und am Anfang Markus Lanz versucht
ihn ja festzulagen, sagt so, antwortet auf die Frage, antwortet auf die Frage.
Er tut es einfach nicht. Und das sind,
genau,
das blüht uns. Deswegen finde ich das auch so krass, dass diese.
Genau diese Leute, die es irgendwie schaffen und dann am Ende irgendwelche bescheuerten
Fremdwörter zu verwenden,
weil sie den Begriff Korruption nicht kennen, weil alle darum herumtanzen müssen,
dass Philipp Amthor einfach sehr, sehr, sehr den Eindruck erweckt,
dass er einfach ein korrupter Hund ist.
Und dass er seine Position im Parlament für wirtschaftlichen Vorteil genutzt hat.
Und dass das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz eine Rolle daran gespielt hat, dies aufzudecken.
Und diesen Eindruck, dass Philipp Amthor einfach nur ein korrupter Hund wäre,
vollständig aufgeklärt hat, denn dieser Eindruck hat sich ja nicht erhärten lassen,
weil ja tatsächlich am Ende durch unterschiedliche Untersuchungen für mich nicht
ganz nachvollziehbar erklärt wurde, dass das alles vollkommen rechtens war.
Das ist ja die Hermeneutik der Korruption,
die da zur Anwendung kam, weshalb Philipp Amthor uns als Vertreter unserer Interessen
allein seinem Gewissen verpflichtet, uns erhalten geblieben ist.
Insofern hat er doch in dieser Diskussion überhaupt nichts zu verlieren.
Trotzdem versucht er dieses Thema die ganze Zeit zu vermeiden.
Man fragt sich, warum eigentlich?
40 Sekunden haben wir noch. Du hast gemeint, wir sollten uns das komplett anhören.
Wollen wir das noch machen?
Ja, müssen wir ja.
Komm, das ertragen wir jetzt auch noch.
Also, ey, wenn der nicht den Joghurt im Turmbeutel hätte, ne?
So, pass auf, diese, also, ey, was da ja drin steht ist, wir haben...
Und steht bevor, in den USA eine Regierung von Donald Trump.
In Deutschland eine Regierung unter Führung von Friedrich Merz.
Und das Erste, was denen einfällt, und das sind ja nun wirklich Friedrich Merz,
der ist ja Mittelständler mit so einem Jahresgehalt von einer Million und einem
kleinen Flugzeug, mit dem er dann da hin will.
Aber sonst ist er einfach ein totaler Mittelständler.
Und da fragt man sich ja, warum diese Mittelständler, die für BlackRock arbeiten,
so eine, was ist BlackRock? Ja, eigentlich so eine,
Kleinanleger, Kleinanleger eigentlich.
Mittelständischer,
Vermögensverwalter.
Das sind ja Leute aus der Mitte der Gesellschaft. Und jetzt können die endlich hier für uns,
demokratisch ihrem Gewissen verpflichtet regieren und das Erste,
was denen einfällt, ist, dass wir Informationsfreiheitsgesetz abschaffen.
In der bisherigen Form.
In der bisherigen Form. Da haben wir was Besseres für euch. Da werden die bestimmt,
bestimmt werden die sich für Transparenz engagieren, ja?
Ja, also da müssen wir auf jeden Fall noch gut hinschauen, dass es da der neuen
Regierung nicht gelingt, da irgendwas,
durchzuschummeln, was wirklich die Situation verschlechtern würde, weil das ist nicht okay.
Und ich muss dazu sagen, Arne Semsrott, ja regelmäßig bei uns in der Sendung,
immer gern gesehener Gast, sagt ja auch, er will eigentlich ja auch nicht,
dass es das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz noch länger gibt.
Er möchte eigentlich ein Transparenzgesetz.
Dass nämlich diese Dinge gar nicht angefragt werden müssen, sondern einfach da sind.
Dass es quasi den gläsernen Staat gegenüber den.
Privaten Bürgerinnen und Bürgern gibt. Und natürlich kann ich mir übrigens auch
vorstellen, dass das IFG mitunter ein Schmerz ist für Behörden,
die dann nachträglich sich bemühen müssen,
Unterlagen zu veröffentlichen.
Und übrigens, jetzt schließt sich der Kreis zum ersten Thema,
stellen wir ja auch regelmäßig fest, dass dann in Behörden die Anweisung ist,
macht bitte keine Aktenvermerke, schreibt bitte keine E-Mails,
sondern wir haben hier so eine Signal-Gruppe, Telegram-Gruppe,
WhatsApp-Gruppe, hast du nicht gesehen.
Going dark.
Going dark ist das, was sie natürlich jetzt machen, wenn sie sehen,
dass ihnen potenziell der Bürger und die Bürgerin auf die Finger schaut und
Dinge aus dem Kontext gerissen werden.
Und ich kann diese Sorge übrigens tatsächlich nachvollziehen,
weil wenn Dinge aus dem Kontext gerissen werden, ist das sehr ungünstig.
Wir haben das beispielsweise gesehen bei den Protokollen der Corona-Kommission.
Die haben dann diskutiert über den Verlauf der Pandemie und das war eine Gruppe,
die gedachte, dass sie quasi in einem geschlossenen Kreis spricht.
Und das hatte auch zur Folge, dass da mitunter auch mal eine Hypothese oder
eine steile These oder eine provokante Frage gestellt wurden,
die in diesem Kreise nicht alle als vollständige, als full in,
sondern hat halt eine Gruppe diskutiert.
Und irgendwelche Leute haben Protokolle geschrieben und am Ende sind die unter
Informationsfreiheitsgesetz an die Öffentlichkeit gekommen.
Dann gab es eine ganze Menge Fragen, die sich darauf bezogen,
weil da dann auch noch Namen und sonst was drin geschwärzt waren und so weiter.
Da haben sich die ganzen Covidioten wieder gesagt, hier guck mal,
da ist ein geschwärzter Name, der entscheidet irgendwas, wer ist das denn,
das ist ja hier eine Schattenstruktur und so weiter und so fort.
Mit anderen Worten, es gibt diese Beispiele, wenn quasi offene Diskussionen stattfinden,
irgendwelche internen für die TeilnehmerInnen bestimmten Protokolle geschrieben
werden und das dann am Ende in der Öffentlichkeit einen ...
Unschönen, wenn nicht sogar verzerrten Eindruck vermittelt.
Also diese Beispiele gibt es. Insofern kann ich verstehen, dass Leute sagen, pass auf,
wenn wir hier so ein Informationsfreiheitsgesetz haben und Angst haben müssen,
dass alles, was irgendjemand jemals irgendwo schreibt, sagt oder sonst was,
am Ende in einzelnen Teilen aus dem Kontext gerissen wird.
Dann erschwert das unsere Arbeit.
Vor allem unsere Lobby-Tätigkeit für unsere Geldgeber, aber natürlich auch unsere
Arbeit, unsere legitime Arbeit in der Behörde oder im Ministerium.
Deswegen sagt Arne ja, und nicht nur Arne, also alle, die quasi der Idee der
Demokratie und des gläsernen Staates anhängen,
dass es ein Transparenzgesetz braucht, wo man gar nicht mehr verlangt,
dass diese Dinge partiell in Einzelstücken auf Anfrage veröffentlicht werden,
sondern dass möglichst alles veröffentlicht wird.
Also quasi ein DDoS auf Verschwörungsideologinnen.
Dass du quasi durch vollständige Transparenz alles nachvollziehbar machst und
in diese Richtung dich bewegst.
Weil klar, die IFG-Anfragen sind partiell.
Und ich kann quasi diese Sorge verstehen, dass dann aus dem Kontext gerissen
so ein Brief mit dem Briefpapier eines Bundestagsabgeordneten einen komplett
falschen Eindruck erweckt von seiner Tätigkeit im Rahmen seines Gewissens.
Ja, na gut, wir sollten auf jeden Fall hier mal noch genauer hinschauen,
wie sich das entwickelt.
Schon mal ganz gut, dass es so eine öffentliche Reaktion gibt.
Die öffentlichen Reaktionen sind sehr, sehr umfassend. Es gibt einen öffentlichen
Brief übrigens und eine Petition.
Ich gucke mal gerade, wie weit diese Petition inzwischen ist.
Den Link haben wir natürlich in den Shownotes.
409.000.
Als ich das letzte Mal geguckt habe, waren das noch irgendwie 220.
Also 409.000 Leute, es gibt diesen öffentlichen Brief.
Wir als CCC haben uns auch dazu geäußert und natürlich dem öffentlichen Brief angeschlossen.
Aber das ist natürlich nicht das einzige, die einzige Missetat,
die diese Koalition plant.
Aber ich würde sagen, zwischendurch können wir so eine kleine Gute Nachricht einstreuen.
Hast du den Jingle?
Ich den Jingle habe? Was für eine Frage.
Börsen im Keller,
Aber mir geht es ganz gut, denn tatsächlich ist eine meiner größeren Sorgen gefallen.
Es sieht aktuell danach aus, dass der Open Tech Fund, der ja auch gemaskt und
getrumped wurde und gedoscht wurde,
nun doch erstmal weiterarbeiten kann. Da haben sie sich irgendwie anders überlegt.
Ja, da gab es also Protest. Und erst mal scheint dieses Projekt dann doch weiterzugehen.
Das war es aber auch schon. Kommen wir zurück zu den schlechten Nachrichten.
Open Technology, also in den USA sozusagen.
Da, wo unter anderem halt Signal und auch so Sachen wie Let's Encrypt gefördert werden.
Das wäre jetzt auch ein bisschen doof gewesen, wenn man jetzt mal so alle,
die Hälfte der Zertifikate im Internet, also im World Wide Web mal so eben hätte wegsterben lassen.
So, ja, da.
Ich muss das kurz ein bisschen ein,
Norden. Es war so, Let's Encrypt, die Entwicklung wurde vom OTF finanziert.
Damals hier Peter Eckersley und
so, mit denen haben wir damals auch schon irgendwie schön darüber geredet.
Ich glaube, Let's Encrypt wird inzwischen von der IFF oder auch inzwischen von
Direktspenden getragen.
Ähnlich wie Signal, wo es halt die Entwicklung war, also der OTF,
ähnlich wie dieser Prototype-Fund, den wir in Deutschland haben,
dem natürlich derartige Erfolge bisher noch nicht geglückt sind,
aufgrund sehr viel geringerer Fördervolumina. Ja.
Und ich glaube, auch Signal wird nicht mehr nennenswert oder nicht mehr in großen
Teilen vom OTF getragen.
Wenn, dann wären es sowas wie Weiterentwicklungen, Features oder so.
Das kannst du ja mal im OTF beantragen.
Der Betrieb dieser etablierten Systeme wird dann nicht mehr vom OTF gefundet.
Aber die Entwicklung der nächsten, irgendwie vielleicht mal so geschlossene
Benutzergruppe, Nutzergruppe-Signal für Regierung.
Nein, das wird natürlich nicht passieren.
Aber es ist schon eher so eine Anschubfinanzierung für diese Entwicklung.
Let's Encrypt wäre nicht zum Ende gekommen, aber wir hätten nicht das nächste
Let's Encrypt bekommen.
Das ist so ein bisschen, muss ich zumindest zum Kontext des OTFs noch dazu sagen.
Ich gucke gerade mal, was Let's Encrypt selber sagt, also das Funding steht
tatsächlich auf breiteren Beinen.
Da gibt es auch Google und AWS, die da reinwerfen und im Übrigen auch der Sovereign
Tech Fund aus Deutschland steht hier noch vor dem Open Technology Fund.
Der da aber auch noch drin steht. Den Teil, den Google dann nicht finanzieren
konnte, den haben wir dann mit deutschen Steuermitteln noch hinterhergekippt.
Das ist natürlich Das ist natürlich auch nochmal gut.
Mag sein, dass der OTF aktuell das aber in meiner Wahrnehmung und ich kenne
eigentlich deren Ausschreibungsrichtlinien wie gesagt ganz gut,
Weiterentwicklungen, das auf jeden Fall, aber nicht Betrieb.
Ja, das weiß ich nicht. Hier wird nur zwischen einem Diamond-Level,
Platinum-Level und Gold-Level unterschieden und einem Silver-Level gibt es auch noch.
Da sind ganz viele dann unterwegs, aber immerhin, so die eben genannten alle im Diamond-Level.
Also was das jetzt bedeutet, wer da wirklich wie viel Geld konkret und andere
Werte reinwirft, das geht natürlich jetzt hier aus dieser Seite nicht hervor.
Es ist erstmal diversifiziert, aber es ist natürlich klar, also auch Tor und
solche Projekte haben von dem Open Technology Fund profitiert und wenn das jetzt
alles so weiterläuft, umso besser.
Ich bin übrigens hier in der 23 Renewing Sponsors von Let's Encrypt,
da sehe ich den OTF jetzt aktuell nicht aber wie gesagt,
also OTF unter den Förderrichtlinien befindet sich es muss was Neues entstehen
und das sicherlich wird sowohl Signal als auch Let's Encrypt als auch, was weiß ich,
OpenVPN OpenVPN ist aktuell,
unter den OTF-geförderten Projekten.
Das ist jetzt auch langzeit etabliert und dann wird irgendein Feature dazu entwickelt
und dann können die sich dafür bewerben.
Aber okay, viel zu lange gute Nachrichten. Kommen wir zur nächsten schlechten.
Was haben wir denn da? Ah ja, Chatkontrolle. Ja, hatten wir lange nicht.
Also Vorratsdatenspeicherung soll ja eh wieder kommen und jetzt möchte die Union,
Messenger zur Entschlüsselung und Weitergabe von Kommunikationsinhalten verpflichten.
Das ist also nicht nur wir lassen eine AI mitlesen, sondern naja,
pass auf, wir möchten die Dinger gerne abhören.
Klar, wenn demnächst unser Feind die USA sind, bevor die in irgendeiner Signalgruppe
entscheiden, dass sie uns bombardieren, wollen wir natürlich mitlesen.
Kann ich verstehen, also das hat da auch schon irgendwie ein paar positive Aspekte,
aber klar, sie möchten gerne durch Hintertüren auf den System einer Umgehung,
der Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung aus dem Weg gehen.
Das haben wir hier hundertfach diskutiert und wenn das jetzt in die Pläne dieser Koalition,
aufgenommen wird, dann werden wir uns in den nächsten paar Jahren mit beschäftigen.
Hatten wir schon erwähnt, dass die AfD inzwischen gleich offen mit der CDU ist.
Man fragt sich, wie das nur sein kann, wo die CDU sich doch so unglaublich engagiert
für die Demokratie und den gläsernen Staat und die Menschenrechte und so eine
richtig positive Vision hat für die Zukunft dieses Landes.
Ist, verstehe ich überhaupt nicht, dass die Leute das Original wählen.
Kommen wir zum nächsten.
Was meinst du mit gleich auf? Also gleich auf in was?
In der Beliebtheit oder nicht? Also das war, ist das nicht an mir vorbeigescrollt?
Ich glaube, jetzt muss ich den Link dazu finden. Aber wenn du die Sonntagsfrage stellst.
Dann... Sonntagsfrage. Achso, also meinst du, wenn jetzt Bundestagswahl wäre,
wen würden sie wählen und dann ist AfD und CDU auf dem gleichen Level, sagst du?
Im ARD-Deutschland-Trend.
Eine Mehrheit der Deutschen rechnet mit einem Bündnis von SPD und Union.
Allerdings lässt die Union federn und jetzt hast du die Union schwächer und
die AfD mit Höchststand und damit nahezu gleich auf.
Also 24 versus 26%.
Gut, dann muss man noch hier über...
Wir könnten überlegen, ob wir einfach die kompletten Erkenntnisse der Polizei
in eine Datenbank schreiben, die Peter Thiel gehört.
Das wäre so das Letzte, was mir noch einfallen würde, um die Woche abzurunden.
Ja, also um das jetzt hier, damit das hier nicht irgendwie so allzu positiv
endet, mit Weltwirtschaft irgendwie 20 Prozent runter,
Transparenz des Staates abgeschafft, Philipp Amthor bei Markus Lanz,
CDU gleichauf mit AfD.
Damit wir hier nicht wie Bruder Leichtfuß ins Wochenende gehen,
könnte man noch überlegen, ob der Bundesrat nicht einfach sagt,
wir wollen eine Datenanalyse- Plattform von Peter Thiel bundesweit nutzen. Bayern geht voran.
Wir wissen ja, in zehn Minuten.
Bayern macht es vor, die kippen die Polizei Daten echt in dieses Analyse-System
von Peter Thiel, dessen C-Zone J.D.
Vance ist, nur diejenigen, die sich hier vergessen haben, und dessen Kollege,
aus PayPal-Zeiten Elon Musk ist.
Und man hat längere Zeit gedacht, Peter Thiel wäre der Schlimmere.
Ist er vielleicht auch.
Ja, die liefern sich ein Kopf-an-Kopf-Rennen.
Also Elon Musk ist definitiv der Peinlichere. Also Peter Thiel scheint ja noch
so Umgangsformen zu haben und so halbwegs alle beisammen.
Aber das ändert halt nichts, dass er eigentlich so ein bisschen das Zentrum
oder zumindest ein Teil des Zentrums dieses libertären Fiebertraums der Umgestaltung
des Staates ist und all solche Ideen wie Freedom City, und so weiter, all das,
findet eben auch so bei ihm sehr viel Anklang und er wirft halt auch eine ganze
Menge Geld drauf und hat halt unter anderem, da haben wir ja auch schon hier
ausführlich drüber gesprochen, eben JD Vance jetzt sozusagen durchgesetzt und
jetzt sehen wir ja, was wir davon haben,
und du redest natürlich jetzt von Palantir, von dem Unternehmen,
was Peter Thiel schon vor langer Zeit gegründet hat und was hier auch schon
öfter mal ein Thema war und die sind halt so im Bereich Datenanalyse ganz wild
unterwegs und bieten Produkte an für Behörden und für auch für Polizei.
Ja, kippt doch eure Daten hier rein, wir kriegen das irgendwie alles schon ganz
gut analysiert, um die Bösewichte zu finden.
Es ist ein paar Jahre her, dass ich die zweifelhafte Freude hatte,
Peter Thiel kennenzulernen und die Ansichten, der damals vertreten hat, die waren noch wirklich,
out of this world.
Das war wirklich, du hast eigentlich gedacht so, Alter, wie kannst du so,
so schlecht gelaunt, aggressiv und dystopisch unterwegs sein.
Das ist, also die Ansichten von Peter Thiel auf die Welt, das ist das,
was sich gerade realisiert.
Das waren Zeiten, da hätte ich noch einen Tesla auf der Straße zu sehen,
habe ich noch als positiv wahrgenommen.
Da war der schon genau so drauf, wie Donald Trump heute Politik macht. und,
es ist ja, also ich glaube, das ist ja schon so, dass der J.D.
Vance ist doch so ein Ziehsohn von Peter Thiel, den hat der eigentlich da positioniert.
Ja, also der hat,
es gab da, der hat irgendwie bei ihm im Unternehmen angefangen und dann fand
er ihn wohl irgendwie ausreichend formbar und hat dann eben schon seinen,
Kandidatenlauf in welcher Bundesstaat war das jetzt nochmal,
war das Utah, wo er zum Senator geworden ist, kurz vorher.
Den schon finanziert und ja, dann letzten Endes natürlich auch seine,
Vizepräsidentschaft sagen wir mal durchgesetzt. Also da die Argumente geliefert.
Entschuldigung, Ohio war das nicht Utah.
Und genau dieser Peter Thiel hat mit Palantir, das sind doch,
das muss man auch immer, ich bin nicht so firm mit Herr der Ringe,
aber Palantir ist irgendwie das böse Überwachungsding.
Die sehenden Steine.
Ja, ich bin in dem Lore auch nicht so unterwegs.
Genau, aber das ist, also Leute, die Herr der Ringe-Firmen sind,
wissen, dass das nichts Gutes ist, wenn jemand eine Firma gründet und die sogar Palantir nennt.
Das ist irgendwie so, als würdest du die Sauron Technologies nennen oder so.
Das ist wirklich, das ist entweder unglücklich oder ein schlechtes Omen,
wenn du deine Firma so nennst.
Ja, es wundert natürlich auch nicht, dass Bayern sofort sagt,
lass uns alles da reinwerfen, my precious.
Und man fragt sich wirklich, wie du hier in Europa, wie die jetzt alle da sitzen
und sagen, okay, die in den USA sind alle durchgeknallt.
Und wir müssen erst mal gucken, ob wir irgendwie, also unsere irgendwie Zölle
hast du nicht gesehen, noch und nöcher.
Die US-Regierung hasst uns offensichtlich. Und was könnten wir jetzt wohl tun?
Was wäre jetzt so ein guter Schritt in Richtung digitale Souveränität?
Lass uns doch einfach, hier kommen wir auf der Webseite, da steht AI-Powered
Automation for every decision.
Das klingt nach einer sehr guten Idee. Lass uns das mal klicken.
Lass uns das am besten zum Kern unserer inneren Sicherheit machen.
Auf Anhieb fällt mir eigentlich keine dümmere Idee ein.
Ja, aber das weckt natürlich alles Begehrlichkeiten.
Also jetzt, wo alle gelernt haben, wie toll man Texte durchsuchen kann mit diesen
ganzen Large Language Models, möchte man natürlich dann auch mal seine eigenen
Polizeiakten entsprechend analysieren können, in Anführungsstrichen.
Und das weckt Begehrlichkeiten, zumindest in Bayern.
Mal schauen, wie weit sich das Thema noch in der Koalition auch rumspricht.
So, dann haben wir noch ein Thema, das nehmen wir aber in der nächsten Sendung
dann eher nochmal genauer auseinander, Altersverifikation.
Es gibt ja den DSA, den Digital Services Act und dem ist schon so ein bisschen
vorgesehen gewesen, dass man sagt,
dass Anbieter von Online-Plattformen sich daran halten müssen und dass sie Alterskontrolle machen müssen.
Und das ist schon so ein kleines Problemchen, weil es gibt einmal die ab 18
Inhalte, wir als gute, brave Bürger des Internets wissen, wenn da steht ab 18, dann wird es ernst.
Da gehen wir lieber woanders hin und gucken Katzenbilder für Leute ab 13 oder sogar ab 6.
Und für diejenigen, die Inhalte ab 18 zugänglich machen, wird natürlich in zunehmendem
Maße ein Druck aufgebaut, dass sie sicherstellen, dass die Leute,
die sich das angucken, auch wirklich 18 sind.
Und üblicherweise ist der einzige Weg, ein gewisses Alter nachzuweisen,
das Vorzeigen eines Ausweises.
Das ist das Einzige, was dein Geburtsdatum und damit auch dein Alter wirklich amtlich dokumentiert.
Und die Aufgabe, die da jetzt gelöst werden muss, ist, ist es denn möglich,
dass ich auf der Webseite ab 18 nachweisen kann, dass ich 18 bin und zwar nicht,
indem ich sage, ich bin 18,
sondern indem eine dritte Institution, in diesem Fall der deutsche Staat oder die Bundesdruckerei,
quittieren, ja, der ist wirklich schon 18.
Ohne, dass die Seite am anderen Ende oder die verifizierende Seite sagen kann,
guck mal, der Linus, der guckt im Internet Katzenvideos ab 18.
Oder was auch immer. Er möchte, was ist ab 18, Tim? Ich weiß gar nicht, ich mache sowas nicht.
Aber vielleicht würde ich jemals auf die Idee kommen, bei dieser Stelle am Internet,
wo steht, hier geht das ab 18 Internet los, zu sagen, weiter,
dann wäre es wahrscheinlich gut, oder in meinem Interesse, wenn weder die Seite,
die ich da besuche, weiß, wer ich bin, noch der Staat weiß, wer ich bin.
Welche Seite ich besuche. Und das Einzige, wie man das noch schlimmer machen
könnte, wäre, indem man ein privatwirtschaftliches Unternehmen dazwischen schaltet, dass beides weiß.
Und tatsächlich sieht es gerade danach aus, wir werden es in der nächsten Sendung
noch mal anschauen, ich mache das jetzt quasi einen Teaser.
Dass diese Büchse der Pandora.
Diese Quadratur des Kreises, angegangen werden soll mit einer App und zwar von
niemand Geringerem als,
ich lese nochmal nach, ob das wirklich stimmt, weil es könnte auch sein,
dass ich das als Witz gesehen habe und gar nicht auf Anhieb quasi mir nur eingebildet habe.
Aber ja, es gibt
eine technische Spezifikation von der EU-Kommission und die soll jetzt programmiert
werden von T-Systems und dem schwedischen Unternehmen SkyTales.
Da kann ja eigentlich nichts schief gehen. Insofern sind wir auch am Ende der
Sendung angelangt und können ab jetzt ruhigen Gewissens im Internet auf die ab 18 Bereiche gehen.
Einfach kurz unseren Personalausweis zeigen. Nein, also es geht hier darum,
natürlich irgendwie einen pseudonymen Altersnachweis zu schaffen und da ist
der Unterschied entscheidend, weil ein pseudonymer Altersnachweis ist nicht
ein anonymer Altersnachweis.
Und technisch ist das etwas, was schon lange gelöst ist.
In der Bundesrepublik Deutschland jedoch nicht. Und ein Pseudonymer Altersnachweis
hätte eben die unschöne Eigenschaft, dass das Pseudonym an irgendeiner Stelle auflösbar wäre.
Und das hieße, ihr müsstet euch sehr genau überlegen, welche Altersnachweise
ihr im Internet noch erbringen möchtet und welche nicht.
Aber das ist ein Ausblick. Da reden wir mit Leuten in den nächsten Sendungen drüber.
Auch das neben Vorratsdatenspeicherung, Angriff auf die Informationsfreiheit,
Angriff auf die Verschlüsselung, eines der Themen,
die wir in der Blackrod-Koalition vor uns haben werden.
Ja, so viel von unserer Hermeneutik.
Die Hermeneutik Ich habe das nochmal nachgeschlagen.
Also da steckt tatsächlich was dahinter. Es ist eigentlich die Hermeneutik des Verdachts,
versus der Hermeneutik des Vertrauens und das handelt sich dabei um einen Stil
der literarischen Interpretation, bei dem Texte mit Skepsis gelesen werden,
um ihre angebliche unterdrückten und verborgenen Bedeutungen aufzudecken.
Besondere Vertreter davon, Karl Marx, Sigmund Freud und Friedrich Nietzsche.
Okay.
Ja. Das ist sozusagen so ein bisschen, ich würde sagen, die Hermeneutik des
Verdachts ist auch sehr stark in uns.
Ich würde mich mal mit Philipp Amthor gerne über die Hermeneutik der Korruption unterhalten.
Das wäre so ein Gespräch. Da wäre der herzlich eingeladen.
Ja.
Vielleicht kann er mir noch mal die beiden Begriffe erklären.
Ich habe offensichtlich vollständig falsche Konzepte von Korruption und Hermeneutik.
Das kann er mir noch mal erklären.
Tja. Ist ja auch alles nicht so einfach. Der kennt sich schon wirklich gut aus
mit Philosophie und Literatur.
Ich nicht.
Nee, deswegen lassen wir uns ja noch mal von dem erklären.
Okay, Leute. ihr könnt ja eure literarisch-philosophischen Erkenntnisse dann
bei uns in die Kommentare reinschreiben.
Unten, wie man so schön sagt, im Internet. Unten reinschreiben.
Und dann lesen wir das nächste Mal vor. Könnt ihr euch einreihen mit Karl Marx
und Sigmund Freud und Nietzsche.
Nietzsche.
In bester Gesellschaft sozusagen.
Gut, dann machen wir den Deckel drauf und verabschieden uns ganz brav. Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Ciao, ciao.
Bis dann.